[Music]
hello my name is Julian Polanco I'm a
national master from the state of
Missouri and today we'll be going over
the Cochran gambit requested by my
highest rated viewer I assume wait
actually yeah Aaron sorry Brandon
Jacobson is way higher rated than Hans
Neiman all right efore a five-night of
three nine of six the Petrov defense
white plays Knight takes e5 the main
move d6 also the main move and here most
people and most computers and everything
else would play Knight of three but
today we'll be exploring the crazy
realms of Knight takes f7 so after nine
six of seven this this is our starting
position black basically has to play
King takes f7 White has two pawns for
for piece and black skin is exposed now
the question is does white have enough
compensation to be better for equality
or for what and well let's let's explore
so the main move here is actually just
to leave the pawn on e4 Haney and to
play d4 now I'll ask the class at large
what happens if black plays Knight takes
e4 first tactics a tactical puzzle white
to play and win yes yes
Bensimon yes queen h5x clam and if g6
that's correct for king the king and the
knight and white reaches a very pleasant
position where he's no longer down a
piece and black sakina's exposed
although black has some mild
compensation after King g7 queenie for a
knight c6 basically a black will never
do this but why does white is close to
winning not then he's significantly
better so anyway the best move here is
to play C 5 but there are there are
other most Bishop e7 and Bishop e6 so
you have to look at the developing moves
first what after Bishop e7 white just
precedes by developing another piece
Knight to c3 c6 and Bishop to d3 so
White's trying to bring all of his
pieces into the game and he has lots of
central control and he's preparing to
castle while blacks keen is still weak
on f7 White has a slight initiative
let's look at a game that starts in this
position so this is a game between
jahnava verse make these georgian names
make it really Knight of three takes
knight of seven Cain takes d4 Bishop e7
93 c6 so black is limiting the Knights
the Knights path taken control of the d5
square and B 5 squared Bishop d3 rookie
a so black is artificially castling and
trying to get his pieces out and if and
if he's successful then he'll just be a
piece to the good so white castles can
g8 and then you plays h3
why would white play h3 can anybody
answer that question
backdoor for the king can you elaborate
that's possibly true in some endings
there would be some rocky eight mate
that we're avoiding but there's
something a little bit more more
important than serious right so we're
taking control of the g4s square so the
knight can't go to g4 that's correct but
more importantly black can't play Bishop
g4 which would maybe harass our queen
and we wouldn't have a very good square
to move to so blac proceeds with Knight
a six a 3y is a three plate same thing
right white is preventing black from
play Knight before and after and and the
knight is kind of off sides it's not
really contributing to Black's position
so this exchange of moose has probably
benefited white a little bit more than
its benefit of black because the knight
is little silly on a six and A three is
useful preventing future Bishop befores
and ninety four sg6 and now white goes
forward we play f4 oh whoops I killed it
Knight of seven let's return to our
position 96-83 white goes forward with
f4 so whenever your opponent plays a
move like g6 this usually gives you like
a hook to attack right this is a
weakness and what if white is successful
in his attack because basically white
White's plan is just to go a 5 or f5
he's gonna blow up in black skin side
and then he's going to deliver check me
of course if he's not successful then
black will just be a piece up and it's
probably winning so Bishop FA and white
plays which move which advanced would
you rather play here ee v or f5 actually
I would already probably prefer white in
this position because it's very easy to
understand the plans I just push all my
pawns forward and I deliver me with
black you have to like find some
maneuvers that are subtle subtleties
never been my strong suit and it's hard
I mean Bishop f8 it opens up the rook
problem with E 5 immediately just to
answer that question really fast is that
after D takes e5 if we were we would
want to play F takes e5 right because F
takes e5 we would still have two Center
pawns and we would open the F file but
unfortunately as Mario mentioned we have
activated one of black's pieces that
being the queen and after Queen takes d4
we would lose all of our compensation
and pawns black would just be up a piece
and winning so that's why that's why we
play f5 over e 5 because we want to open
up the position because we have the
initiative we have more development and
blacks kinas weak but we shouldn't allow
the Queen to reach the d4 square I mean
II 5 is also I mean it's not that bad
because you can recapture with the D
pawn but once again we want to open the
F file we don't want and there's no need
to activate blacks Queen
so f5 black black takes if you don't
take then I take on g6 and I play Bishop
g5 yes this was the Cochran gambit
inspired by Preston Smith a local chess
chess player here in st. Louis and
Brandon Jacobson my highest rated
viewer-requested it he's like twenty
four thirty so so I decided to give him
what he wants f5 G takes up five each
sorry after each takes Bishop g5 so
white is putting black in a pin right so
this what kind of what quick quiz
what kind of pin is this a relative pin
or an absolute pin why what's the
difference
right that's correct yeah that's correct
all right so this is a relative pen and
would it be a good idea for black to
capture more pawns how yes that's that's
correct white is completely winning
after this so the the pawn not only is
the knight pin to the Queen the pawn is
also pinned because if you take then you
lose your knight
so there's two pins going on it's a
crossfire anyway so white develops a
piece and I mean I can take the pawn on
f5 anytime I want so and just proceed
with development Bishop g7 protecting
the knight now it is a possibility to
take on e4 although if I were to pass
like let's say I play a stupid move
let's say rook b1 right that seems
pretty stupid is it a good idea to take
on e4 now
okay so it is true that that went to
tempo but how should so youth let's have
a show of hands who thinks F takes e4 is
a good move raise your hand yeah because
of this pin right yeah that's that's
correct
so Knight takes e4 and there are three
pieces on f6 and there's only two
defending the rook would have to go back
to defend the f6 square or the knight
and white would just have a winning an
advantage I assume by just taking and
playing Queen h5 this seems pretty
devastating yeah so you still can't take
on e4 so white just plays King h1 now a
lot of you see good players are scared
like all the time if you if you ask a
good player like what's going on in the
position they're usually like my
opponent wants to do this this this and
this right they're never like I want to
do this they think of what their
opponents wants to do and how they can
stop whatever whatever their pawns want
to do now it might not seem important to
the Kings on g1 but in the future there
might be some Queen b6 in the d4 pawn is
hanging with check there's always
tactics going on so it's hard to play d5
basically just stepping off of the g1 to
a7 diagonal is very useful for White's
position and once again as black isn't
really threatening to take on e4 yet we
can just continue with our developing
moves and this helps this helps my
position a lot so anyway night c7 so
black tries to bring his knight back
into the game he needs to connect
connect his pieces somehow so that they
defend each other maybe the Knights come
in to e6 to kick the bishop
and then at f8 and it will be useful
defender Queen f3 so White's burning
more of his pieces into the attack
putting more pressure on f5 and in this
opening or it's alright now in this
opening but in these types of positions
you really want to take back on f5 with
a piece you don't want to take back with
a pawn y-yes yes you want to have the F
file at your disposal and you don't want
to take that away by putting your pawn
there so you can't take your own pond so
that's gonna close the file forever
right your opponent just gonna leave the
pawn there you want to burn more of your
pieces in and then eventually you want
to take back with a piece if your
opponent forces you to do something else
then you do something else but until
that moment comes you can just keep just
keep developing black isn't really
threatening anything also the Queen puts
more pressure on f6 Queen d7 rook goes
to the e-file now I think it's pretty
clear that White has had a successful
opening this position is better for
white if I think objectively and I mean
practically this is just winning even
though black has an extra piece his
pieces on the Queen side the namely the
a work and the CA Bishop are both
sleeping and all of whites pieces are
contributing to the attack my bishop
will be useful on this diagonal my
bishops putting pressure on f6 and
basically this is a dream come true you
can you could not pay to have a position
this good black proceeds with d5e five
and ninety four so the idea is the idea
of Queen d7 is obviously to get out of
the pen and now black wants to close the
position because if you can manage to
close everything up then eventually
white White's initiative will disappear
and he will be once again a piece of the
are useful square for the night to hop
to as a six-block hitting the pawn and
is hacking the D for weakness anyway
Knight takes e4 x climb now this might
look like a mistake because black just
recaptures right but whites a move what
is the best move do you want so your
pieces are forked if you don't do
something now right then you'll be two
pieces down and two pieces for three
pawns doesn't seem like a very good deal
to me
Bishop c4 check is possible but after
Bishop c4 right and ninety five your
queen sit and if you move let's say to
g3 black has very he has a protected
past pony four and don't forget ease up
a piece I'm gonna burn my pieces out
with tempo because your bishops don't
see you for I can hit it with b5 you'll
have to move away and I'll put my bishop
on b7 and suddenly blacks position is
harmonious
so that would that would be incorrect
after D takes White has a brilliant move
the Brandon Jacobson is already saying
yes
well the bishop takes that is true
however in in the position that arises
after this you have no immediate threats
and probably black has time to just
consolidate with 96 and you are down to
pieces all right
granted to pieces for over four pawns is
better than two pieces for three but
this position I I assume your
compensation isn't enough let's just
check yeah
blacks just way so but White has it's
actually better to realize that the
bishop is one of your most useful pieces
so you want to keep that and you want to
get rid of your rook which isn't
actually doing a lot on this close to
file half-closed file so you get rid of
your rook because after F takes Queen
takes your queen in your Bishop are now
on now on a battery and it's really hard
to stop queen h7 mate and it's it's
rough yeah so like in in this position
bishop f8 and then rock f3 it's this
position is I mean practically very hard
to hard to play with black I mean White
has all of his pieces here you're down a
rook that's true but I mean what what is
his extra rook doing for him it's on a
sleeping so anyway in the game after
rook takes he blacks just played Queen
f7 so now you have three pawns for the
piece and you have two Center pawns and
now a five is weak so that's that's
something you could target in the future
rook h4 inh 7 now the pawn is pinned
again the F pawn is pinned because h7
was fall Bishop e6 c4 rook F 8 g4 Bishop
Bishop takes c4 bishop takes takes takes
now White has this pawn mass these are
to protected as alright two connected
passed pawns rook f7 rook goes to the G
file
Queen now now White has actually allowed
a queen trait because the resulting
endings are good for him even though
white is down a piece the fact that he
has protected past ponds means that the
endings are very pleasant because in the
ending you want to make Queens right so
that's more important than some minor
material deficit and in fact you just
win the piece back immediately f6 if you
move what happens
what happened Bishop Bishop h8 yes
yeah and yeah but you have to interpose
a piece which isn't pleasant at all so
it's much better to just lose the piece
like this and White has a winning
position let us move on to other lines
so we've discovered that after d4 black
can't just develop like normally he has
to somehow react if you played Bishop e7
then we've kind of witnessed what
White's plan is you play like Knight c3
you play by 53 and your eventual plan is
to proceed with your central majority
with F 4 e 5 and just crash through what
happened Bishop e6 is interesting but
the problem is is it eventually it might
get hit with with d5 let's move on let's
move on to the next game so II 45 we
reach our starting position and here
black decides to play Queen e8 so now
he's threatening to take on e4 with
either piece because Queen h5 isn't a
thing or queen e4 would be checked but
you can protect the pawn and now the
same tactic works
so if 94 then Queen h5 and there's no
discovery with the night because black
is always in check and white just picks
the knight backup so d5 is the idea
B 5 there should be 4 Bishop d3 c5
this position is is kind of interesting
c5 is actually a mistake
which is weird because c5 is really
naturally you're putting pressure on d4
and but yeah this position is just just
completely winning for white as you can
see because of the game well we'll go
over but better was ninety four castles
Knight takes pawn takes Bishop takes
rook b1 and black has a piece for a pawn
but once again these pieces aren't
really doing anything right now and why
it has a temporary initiative which
hopefully will collect some material
later on but this position should
objectively be good for or this should
be like equal ish Bishop h6 the point is
if you take then I slide over anyway
should be 643 and this position is good
for well it's like interesting but yeah
it's like it's unclear the computer
can't really make up its mind
it'll get to some conclusion but it's
it's practically like equal but in this
game which is played between a Sol skis
and Froylan off who are two very strong
players I believe they're yeah they're
both grandmasters c5 and white is
already winning because castles takes
takes up six and it turns out the black
skin is just too exposed queen h v g6
queen d5 and it's it's really hard to I
mean it looks like a morphe game right
these are two modern-day grandmasters
and in this opening that seems harmless
enough
they the one guy just loses like he's
you know he's just some beginner g6
queen d5 Queen e6 Queen B 5 it's
important to stay in touch with the
bishop on b4 Bishop e6 there should be
16 takes because if
tics now we can take the bishop on
before that's why the Queen's on b5 Kane
takes rook e1 Keane f6 Bishop g5 k n f7
rook a d1 White has all of his pieces in
the attack literally every single piece
is playing the rook on the D file is
hitting the Queen this is cutting off
the king it's also threatening to go to
e7 and some lines Queen c4 is the thing
Queen b7 to thing in Queens before is
the thing
the Queen has hit black resigned because
he couldn't find a good move here and
he's rated 24 87 and he just got
obliterated like like he was 1800 or
something right look at look at these
piece like what did black do with his
extra material not a lot all right
another soul Sookie's game I think he's
the specialist he he's a highest-rated
guy that plays as consistently anyway
his his opponent after d4 played Queen
e8 again all right hold on
yeah in d5 so we're back into this line
but now Bishop b4 which is an
improvement over c5 because you know
this is but c5 was a mistake in the last
game in this game white black play 94
castles 93 BC three bishops III rook B
196 this is interesting
Bishop b5 King GA so black is putting
pressure on the center and white white
decides that it's better to pin the
knight then have the bishop stay on this
diagonal now this line is probably I
mean this is definitely better than what
the last the last dude did against this
opening but it's it's more threatening
and black should be objectively better
kingi a rook b3 hitting the bishop and
the reason why we gave up the c3 pawn is
so that our rook can move from the Queen
side to the King side the bishop is
sorry a 6 an intermediate move Bishop a4
which seems weird because we're kind of
trapping our own bishop but we're
hitting blacks Bishop so it doesn't
really matter
b5 takes takes and this is another
interesting position how would you
proceed with white what plans would you
use which side of the board would you
play on etc yes okay so basically you
think that this position is equal
because white has some gain side
initiative in exchange for material
right and you want to play rook g3 and
Bishop h6 and bringer Queen actually if
Y were to proceed on the Kings side
right now then he would just be lost
because he's no longer winning there now
there's this rule that I like to use I
mean so far is proven to be true until
somebody corrects me but you divide the
board into quadrants and you count how
much material is in each quadrant and
for an attack to work an attack right
you must be winning by plus two and
material right and right now white has
zero material well I guess the e5 pawn a
little bit right he has almost no
material in this quadrant so his attack
on the King side should not be able to
work and this is a rule that I heard
from Kasparov so anyway um the first
time I heard about it so if you were to
bring your pieces over black would just
develop so like rook g3 he would put his
Bishop on f5 and probably burn his
Bishop back to g6 and his bishop is both
the defender and an attacker on the
Queen side so black would just be up a
piece and be winning let's see this
position yeah is it good for black
anyway so you have to see where your
piece is located right now my rook is on
c3 it's kind of penning the knight to
the pawn because if the knight moves I
take the pawn makes sense so let's let's
actually try to play on the Queen side
and in the center because we have Center
pawns so you notice that this if if we
get our Center pawns moving they could
be devastating which is true yes
Bishop a3 well okay actually this is an
important moment I like to I like to say
this all the time
top players if you notice like in their
games when they're not doing when like
it's like an even position they're not
doing anything what they really like to
do is keep pull their bishops back to
the starting position because the bishop
is actually best located on a starting
square the problem is is usually there's
other pieces in the way so you need to
get them out like the bishop views the
entire board right so if you put it on a
three you only see the Queen side right
however on C on on c1 you CH six and A
three right so bishops work very well
from a distance so you don't really need
to move your bishop your bishop is fine
on c1 you don't need to touch that but
you do need to achieve pawn breaks and a
future pawn break that you might want to
achieve is c2 to c4 because if you get
rid of the d5 pawn then your pawns could
just you know start running so why play
white plays work c5 perhaps intending c2
to c4 at some moment black plays Bishop
e6 f4 so now that the bishops on e6 it's
a future target for f5 how should black
proceed this is like if you don't do
this then you're probably going to lose
immediately
yeah blacks blacks defending the Black
has everything defended the problem here
is that white is threatening to advance
with f5 and if you let me I'll play f6
and then you're really in some trouble
yes that's correct you just want to stop
this majority before it can take off so
Bishop f5 is correct now what should
white do based off of everything I've
told you g4 g4 is is really double-edged
so g4 could be great right like you
could win immediately but also if you do
this then you might be allowing some
shenanigans later with Queen g6 and h5
and then your
Kings actually weak so g6 is a real it's
just really double-edged sword
I started g4 there's something that you
can do which is has no negative effect
on your position basically but it helps
helps you you want to advance your pawns
so g4 is the right idea but remember
your rooks on c5 right why why did you
put your rock on c5 yeah so how do you
attack the D pawn that's correct
c2 to c4 and now after DC for notice we
have two Center pawns
d5 and our pawn start running night
before d6 it's this is a change so white
calculated in this game after d6 takes
takes that this past pawn and the fact
that we have a discovery on the bishop
which is important I'm sure everybody in
this room and at home saw this I mean
Brandon saw it I guess but Bishop sorry
Queen g6 Queen d4 black that's right
white calculated correctly that the
seventh rank being weak and having the
d4 square was enough reason to give up
his central majority and get a passport
normally this is a very dangerous
decision like when you have these types
of positions with white the weight like
the safe way to proceed is to go like
Queen d4 and then like surround this
pawn the problem here is that like black
might be able to play like Bishop d3 and
after rook f3 like it's a game well I
I'm not sure who's better and why I mean
probably objectively blacks better
because he has more pieces I would
rather be white in practical game just
because I mean I don't care who you are
like unless well I mean I do care a
little bit but like if you're if you're
playing Carlsen then maybe he'll figure
everything out but even that like the
2200 level I don't think my opponents
would be able to figure this position
out with black let's just see if this
position is even good for black yeah
it's good for black button like not by
much not at all actually
yeah I would much rather be white I mean
like playing people at my level I feel
like why white would win both sides
every time if I were black I'd lose
every game like guarantee so I know
that's true
I just hope that everybody who's who is
black would lose every game anyway well
that's true but it's a margin of errors
a little bit lower the I'm higher there
anyway
Queen d4 Bishop d3 now oops I have this
arrow showing exactly what the answer is
but yeah rook g5 wins
immediately because if you if you move
your queen away there's too many things
on g7 it's it's hard to defend and if
you move it it's really unfortunate but
you you lose you lose immediately to
Queen ashaming so you would have to play
Bishop g6 and then f5 and I mean like I
know checkmate is the worst possible
position right like that's just
objectively true but I'm gonna make a
strong case that this is worse than
checkmate like this position no because
I I mean like like look at all the
pieces they just don't make sense i
nomination for worst position of the
year it would be this one all right
anyway so white white mist rook g5
because rook e1 is also clearly winning
he wanted to put both of his rooks on
the 7th and then go we're are taking
everything h6 rookie 7 sorry all of my
jokes are original and definitely stolen
from Ben Feingold rookie 7 Queen f6
Bishop b2 it doesn't matter that the
Queen's are traded the attack is shown
enough the rook on h8 doesn't play in G
sevens to week this position is
completely winning for white white is
just way too active rook d8 rook g7 King
f8 Bishop f6 if you take d6 you get made
it on the back rank like that
h5 trying to play rock h6 d7 is nice
every legal move wins here though so d7
just makes things easy because you make
a
da all right let's move on to the next
game
this was not a good idea playing Queenie
8 well the best way to react to this
opening is to immediately put pressure
there are some subtle move order
differences between Knight c3 and d4 but
the best reaction after d4 is to place
c5 and immediately challenge the center
and black is better not winning because
this opening actually isn't as bad as
what people normally would think it is
but but black is better after c5 let's
see let's move on to a game where that
happens now this is a especially fun
game because somebody that's like around
my level like 20 to 30 beat somebody
who's 2600 like this never happens like
me beating 2600 like imagine that
situation it's that's like my best dream
except better so II four and we get to
our starting position and the impossible
happened now 26 hundreds are pretty good
at the chess so they know that c5 is the
best move here takes takes is
practically forced if you play d5 you
lose like that's like you have no
compensation the bishop because you've
put your pawns on light squares the
bishop has no scope anymore no no like
the attack is just dead and black has
the e5 square this is a Benoni where
blacks up a piece so there's no reason
to play this this position with with
white however taking makes a lot of
sense because if you take back I take
your queen so it's uh it's effective but
black is giving up an extra pawn so that
he can get some development because
notice the other lines black wasn't
really developing like Bishop e7 and
rook rook e8 like that developed kind of
like you're putting your king your
artificially castling but white is
getting like a huge center and like just
Chuck mating everybody and our previous
two or three examples I think three
examples but c5 gives up an extra pawn
just to get rid of the central d4 pawn
right the pawn on d4 is centralized and
we need to get rid of it as black takes
knight c6 Bishop c4 Bishop e6 takes
takes castles
so blacks akina's on e6 which I mean I'm
that that happened
white white does not have his pieces
developed this game and black does so
the fact that the king is on e6 like it
looks scary but this position is
actually good for black because I can
always run my King back but at least my
like my pieces are coordinated my rook
on eight is connected to my Queen on da
everything kind of makes sense from
blacks perspective but white also has
his jump so Queenie
keen f7 was played to get his King to
safety does a computer play keno someone
let me just check yeah it doesn't
yeah computer doesn't care it's always
like Queen d7 let's go and it's silly so
add things that like white is better but
what sorry in this position Bishop e6 is
correct yeah and then here yeah keener 7
spine but Queen e2 and it's very unclear
like the computer is unclear but on what
black should do but basically we've
given up an extra pawn to get rid of
white central majority and if both
players were to proceed correctly I'm
sure in correspondence chests like black
would whenever again Queen e8 this is a
practically game though so it's harder
to face over the board Knight c3 takes
on c5 so basically we know our plane is
white right we have one plan and if it
doesn't work then too bad but our plan
is we we push our pawns and win like
that's that's our plan blacks plan is
stop that and then be up a piece so how
do how do 26-hundred handle the position
Bishop g5 94 Queen D 3 so these moves
are just kind of obvious you develop
your piece putting pressure on f6 94
attacking the Queen centralizing the
night Queen d3 this is it's important
not to check because if you check on c4
how does this help blacks position
right so Queenie six and at the very
least we win a temple you aren't
necessarily trained the Queen's because
I can always go back to d3
but now the Queen is more active on e6
and all endings are good for black just
based on the fact that he has more
pieces so queen d3 is better than queen
C for Queen t6 and now white friends
the last piece into the attack very
morphe style right all of the pieces are
contributing to the position there's not
a piece that won't be plain
it looks like the f1 rook isn't doing
anything but it's right that's correct
so once white proceeds with F 45 then he
will be he will be winning
so black needs to do something to stop
that and in this game he did not figure
he did not figure it out rookie 8k niche
1 once again good players they like to i
mean like this does it doesn't look like
it does anything but like 10 or 15 moves
from now there could be a tactic that
Black has that this prevents so this is
just preventing the unexpected h6 Bishop
f6 G takes 95 so can somebody tell me
why it's not a good idea to take with
the Queen I actually disagree the the
knight on d5 looks nice right
but once the Queen moves it doesn't
really it doesn't really I mean it's
it's it's a good move but the reason why
this is uh this is bad is because black
your plan is now faster when I play f4
and e5 your Queen on f6 will be hit all
the 95 I think is also probably a good
move
so anyway Queen takes his Queen takes is
wrong G takes so whenever he 5 happens
now blacks plan is to respond with f5
and close the position of course these
plans don't really work out well for for
black in the loans
because I mean usually like just from
looking browsing through a few games
like he usually gets made it 95 or ship
e7c 396 c4 h 5e 5 so even before opening
the F file he's pushing his pawn into
into blacks territory opening up the
position because you want to get your
queen in and this is a hook right this
is a weakness we can play out for next
move anyway black takes Queen f3 can g7
and once again practically I would much
rather be white like I'm sure this
position is good for black or like equal
but because none of these positions are
good for white like objectively
but it's really really hard to figure
the this kind of thing out over the
board at at any reason like normal level
like I'm sure grandmasters would win
this like every game but most of us
aren't grandmasters and III would assume
that the Y would win the majority of the
games sub 2400 rookie 5 Bishop d8 rook
to e1 rook F 1 check k h6 Queen e3 and
black resigns due to the fact that e 6
is hanging although anyway that's how
2250 SB 2,600 2,600 serves and when they
think their loss let's I want to proceed
to a funny tactic even if I don't get to
talk about the opening because I'm
running out of time but this is a game
between short and sheer off short
playing the white pieces against Sheriff
of course short is known for his crazy
opening so this is just another one of
them efore let me turn that off and we
get to our position context d4 sheriff
is good at chess being like 2700 one of
the world's top players he knows that c5
is the best move takes knight 96 this is
all best Bishop c4 takes takes castles
so we've reached the same position
that was in the last game even Queenie 8
I think but I have to mention really
fast that in this position after Bishop
C hold on this position here takes
Knight c3 for ship C for let me let me
come back to the theory segment so it's
my d5x clan yeah so Bishop c4 here the
best move for black believe it or not is
to play d5 so you can't play Bishop c4
immediately that's why taking is is as
best because after a Bishop c4 d5 black
black gains the initiative after takes
and b5 which I thought was really cool
and interesting because you you're
giving up more material just to distract
White's pieces and if white takes DC 5
right then d5 is best which very few
people I don't know if anybody's play
this a few people I guess but blacks one
like the majority of the game so if you
have this with the black pieces this is
how you basically refute the game but
just just so that we're clear I will I
don't want to lie to anybody like this
this gambit is a little dubious after DC
5 d5 black is close to winning
I think this position is just good for
black point 9 is an unbelievable
advantage in the opening with black
anyway II 5 Queen e8 f for fish of g4
take stakes 94 or should be 396 92 take
take blah blah blah we get to some
position like this and black schemes a
little exposed but if you're playing
with the black pieces I highly encourage
you to study this position and you
should be good
but let's let's go back to short shear
off and these I mean I'm yeah a short 0
not regular shear off just short Sheriff
anyway Nigel short essay in the white
pieces it's it's strange how many like
high rated players don't play d5 here
1996 Bishop e6 so we get to our or last
game basically the same position d5 so
black share of at least knows that the
idea is to be able to play d5 because
you want to recapture c5 with the bishop
you want your night to go to e4 and you
want to claim you have more pieces but
II 5 94 93 take take Queen e6 and it's
funny this game like black just out
plays white for like the entire game
like rook f8 Bishop T for those
positions like not as when like better
as the previous position but it's it's
pretty good like like like is better
like by 0.7 or something g5 is a good
move because the same idea with c5 you
don't want to let white have to center
pawns or two pawns connected you want
them to be all split up and weak so you
play g5 to distract to distract the pawn
Bishop g5 rook f8 and we get to this
position and I mean black is basically
just lost I sorry White's just lost like
the entire game and we get to this
moment here but it's incredible to me
like these guys are so strong
unbelievably strong I will never be as
good as these guys and my like in my
dreams right and I mean the majority of
people on this planet won't be either
but after rook FA so basically sheriff
play is almost a perfect game of chess
this is a very very nice game by Shiro
and he plays rook f8 it is now white to
play and win this it's just how it goes
like there's very few sport like in
sports right if somebody's like
completely winning all the way until the
end like the time like zero want right
like you know that the do tan like one
team's gonna win over another right in
chess it's not the case you could be
winning the entire game you could play
like the best game ever and then in a
blink of an eye it could all be over and
you could lose
yeah it happens happens too happens to a
lot of us man
but luckily for shear off his opponent
didn't see it so this is why it's a play
and win if you don't get it I won't
blame you too much even though I gave
you guys scripts which you didn't read
other than the fact that you had the
opportunity to the opportunity to know
everything beforehand I won't blame you
because these guys also missed it so
anyway it's White's play and win this is
a tactic I don't see very often so I
just I just wanted to show it then Simon
do you know the answer yeah wait to play
yes
Brooke f7 would be unfortunate for white
because of the back rank yeah or c1 yeah
and you have back rank problems so you
that's why rook f8 was played rook f8
was played to distract the rook from the
back rank unfortunately it's a losing
blunder which neither players saw we
have a winner Queen f7 it looks really
stupid right like what what are you
doing and then you realize oh well you
gave up one Queen to make another one
yeah this is very good so you're you're
better than like she are often short
just just want to point that out it must
be because you're attending my classes
alright something similar yeah I I think
I think I know what you're talking about
yeah whenever this occurs I'm really
happy because like it's maybe once every
thousand games well he didn't find it
maybe an on saw this game well it wasn't
sheriff's to find it was shorts to find
out sure short lost immediately by the
way because instead of Queen f7
brilliantly suggested by the audience
short just played Rick g1 and while
black has more pieces and white when
passive so I mean but black just went
like if in in this kind of situation
when you're down material there's no
room for like mediocre move so you need
to play every move perfectly after
you've given up material because if you
don't then you're just I mean it's so
easy to play with more pieces like it's
unbelievably easy black just took
everything and white resigned here
because white has let's be pieces very
simple all right the last game that I
might have to zip through is to Paul of
kramnik where once again both players
botched the opening its Paul off note I
don't know if this was a blitz game or
not I also don't know if the previous
because time
control was not listed here anyway I'll
scroll back up ice that was the only
time I scroll down Bensimon so alright
anyway but anyway it could have been but
okay if these guys play coffeehouse
games they're also pretty good by the
way
kramnik and T'Pol I've never heard of
those guys before I've seen this game I
never heard of the two world champions
knock efore a five takes takes the
audience the audience even knows who
these guys are so no introduction needed
and nicely three is a cool is a cool
move this is a subtlety yes you have a
question oh you're just stretching all
right
c5 now white does not need to play d4
right in fact it's better than the pawn
isn't on d4 so you can just proceed with
Bishop c4 in this position isn't so bad
ix c3 is a really tricky move where the
best reply is Bishop e6 and then you can
improve with d4 so nicely three is
interesting like move order if you want
to trick your opponent's because you can
once again the bishop on e6 is a
potential target for d5 yeah you I mean
if the palm is already on c5 like then
that then the e5 square is permanently
weak but you do need to time d5 really
well because if you play d5 too early
right then you will just lose but if you
have f4 in and then you get to play d5
an e5 like at the same time then for
example a6 which doesn't make any sense
f4 being able to show that white has
ideas d5 and then you go away and an e5
like this would be good for white if you
gave white a million moves that he would
be better anyway you could checkmate
away faster than time but we're getting
sidetracked Bishop c4 Bishop e6 takes
takes d4 so now that the Kings on six it
we don't mind if our corn good
centralized that King goes back to f7
tix
so we kind of transposed 96 Queen e2
Queen
seven queenie 8 would be I think the the
only difference is of white out in
castle yet which means what what does
that mean I will ask you that's one
thing so that's a negative thing right
but what's something positive you have
to be a positive person
the queen is defended well the cumin is
already defended alright the the
positive thing is we can choose which
direction we castle in sometimes we
might want to Castle queenside in one
direction I've never heard of them
either
anyway Queen d7 Bishop III so why does
hinting that he wants to Castle
queenside well D takes prevents that so
black is prevented the whites plan so F
for now
'if I've rook d1 so okay F for obviously
we want to advance our majority sorry I
went a little too fast there habit of
mine rook e8 e 594 I mean if I've hit
the Knights and I ask to move and I
detects the Bishop rook d1 hits the
Queen and we just Castle and we've
reached this position where I mean Black
has more pieces but once again white as
the center a pawn storm we all know the
drill we've seen this like five times
before so but black is pretty strong
he's an ex-world champion so this time
this this is the time for for black King
g6 yeah I mean objectively what I told
you before with d5 that like basically
refutes this line so if you're playing
with black what I said before so II four
takes takes takes Bishop d4 here c5 is
best takes and then d5
this is the best line for black black is
better after d5 yes
the one the rusev that was covered by
Jonathan trance
also check out his video but I that's a
topic for another day
yeah I I won't claim to be an expert
about that at all
Queenie - here we are
Bishop c1 so once again notice he's
pretty high rated so he likes his Bishop
on the starting square it's just the
best place for the bishops be assuming
that all your other pieces are out 94
Queen c4 King g6 h3 hitting the night
the night has to go to is really stupid
square that being h6 so yeah all the
voice pieces are active and since both
players are pretty good and white isn't
just a stronger player white has enough
for like equality so this is why the
game eventually ended in a draw all it
has it had its tips and turns of course
black skein is safe white collects
enough material that the positions
around equal I will encourage you to
also study this game this is T'Pol off
Kramnik from 2016
I assume this is a blitz game that's all
that I have for you tonight
Thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]